Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Le silence.
On ne sait pas trop quoi faire
avec le silence, n’est-ce pas ?
On veut le remplir.
Ça nous gêne d'une certaine façon.
De même, lorsque nous allons au musée
et qu’on se trouve devant une œuvre
qu’on ne connaît pas,
si on n’est pas guidé ou qu’on n’a
pas lu tout ce qu’il y a écrit avant,
on ne sait pas trop quoi faire non plus.
On ne sait pas ce qu’on doit penser,
ce qu’on est censé savoir,
ce que l’œuvre est censée nous dire.
Alors, qu’est-ce qu’on fait ?
Eh bien, on lit tout ce qui est écrit
sur les murs, on lit les cartels,
on prend des audio-guides, on s’informe
et on remplit ce silence aussi.
Lorsque nous allons au musée, très
souvent, nous déambulons par les salles,
nous marchons et nous nous arrêtons
de temps en temps devant une œuvre.
Généralement pas plus de huit secondes.
Ou alors on voit ceci.
Mais que voyons-nous ?
Est-ce que nous regardons ?
Que voyons-nous
quand nous allons au musée ?
Que retenons-nous de tous les tableaux,
de toutes les œuvres que nous voyons ?
Et dans notre vie quotidienne, est-ce
que nous regardons autour de nous ?
Qu’est-ce que nous voyons ?
C’est lors d’une exposition
de Frida Kahlo,
la peintre mexicaine,
à San Paulo au Brésil, où j’habitais,
que j’ai eu le premier déclic
qui m’a amenée vers le slow looking,
la pleine conscience et l’art de regarder.
C’était la première fois qu’on montrait
les tableaux de Frida Kahlo au Brésil
et j’étais très excitée
d’aller voir cette exposition
parce que je n’avais jamais vu
ses œuvres en vrai,
seulement des reproductions.
Je rentre dans la grande salle
d’exposition, pleine de monde,
et là, je m’arrête net,
sidérée.
Je regarde autour de moi
et tout le monde prend des photos
des œuvres ou des selfies.
Un peu ce que nous avons vu là.
En sortant de cette exposition,
j’avais été tellement choquée
que je me suis dit
qu'il fallait absolument faire quelque
chose pour inciter les gens à s'arrêter,
à regarder les œuvres,
mais aussi la vie autour de nous.
Qu’est-ce que c’est l’art de regarder ?
Il s’agit de s’arrêter,
d’être absolument présent
dans le moment,
de regarder avec intention,
de regarder en voulant découvrir.
Un peu comme un enfant
qui regarde un jouet
pour la première fois.
Il le découvre petit à petit
en s’émerveillant.
Mais regarder nécessite du temps,
il faut s'arrêter.
Il faut arrêter ce rythme effréné
que nous menons dans nos vies
et regarder.
Georgia O’Keeffe,
l’artiste américaine, disait :
« Personne ne voit une fleur,
elle est si petite.
On n'a pas le temps.
Et regarder prend du temps,
comme avoir un ami prend du temps. »
J’aime beaucoup cette relation
qu’elle fait entre l’amitié et le regard,
car quand nous pensons à une amitié,
nous pensons à une relation
privilégiée, spéciale, unique.
Lorsque nous regardons une œuvre d’art,
en nous arrêtant,
en étant pleinement conscient,
en étant ouvert à regarder et à
avoir une relation avec cette œuvre,
nous créons une relation
qui n’a pas besoin de savoir.
On n'a pas besoin de savoir
des choses avant.
Il suffit simplement de regarder.
Il ne s'agit pas de savoir,
mais de savoir regarder.
Je vais vous inviter à faire
une petite expérience.
Si mon petit truc là marche,
je vais projeter l’image d’une œuvre,
et j’aimerais que vous la regardiez
pendant quelques secondes en silence.
Qu’avez-vous vu ?
Qui est-ce qui a trouvé le temps long ?
Personne ?
Qui est-ce qui a réussi à regarder
cette image sans penser à autre chose ?
Très bien.
Très souvent, quand on est seul
devant un tableau comme ça,
comme je l’ai dit auparavant,
on ne sait pas s’il faut penser ou voir.
Mais si je vous posais la question :
« Qu’est-ce qui se passe
dans cette image ? »
Peut-être quelqu’un dira :
« Ah, je vois deux femmes.
Et l’une d’elles, celle qui est debout,
est en train de donner un billet
à celle qui est assise. »
Peut-être qu’une autre personne dira :
« Ah non, je ne pense pas.
Je pense que c’est celle qui est assise
qui a donné le billet
à celle qui est debout. »
Et je pourrais demander :
« Mais qu’est-ce que vous avez vu
qui vous fait dire ça ? »
Et cette personne pourra dire :
« Parce que je vois que,
sur la table, il y a du papier,
il y a une plume.
Il me semble qu’il y a
quelque chose d’écrit.
Donc elle a écrit un billet
qu’elle a donné à l’autre personne. »
Peut-être que quelqu’un d’autre dira :
« Moi, je pense que
c’est la maîtresse qui est assise
et la servante qui est debout. »
Et je poserai la même question :
« Qu’est-ce que vous avez vu
qui vous fait dire ça ? »
Et la personne pourra me répondre :
« Celle qui est assise porte
une robe qui semble être en satin.
Elle a de l’hermine,
elle porte des bijoux.
Tandis que celle qui est debout
est habillée d’une façon
très simple et sans ornements. »
Et ainsi de suite.
Au bout de 30 minutes,
chacun aura dit ce qu’il a vu, ressenti.
Ses observations.
Chaque observation viendra
s’ajouter à celles des autres
comme des couches successives
de signification.
Bien entendu, il y aura des avis
très différents, parfois contraires,
mais ça n’a pas d’importance,
ça ne vient qu’enrichir
notre compréhension de cette œuvre.
Et ça nous apprend la tolérance.
Admettre, accepter que
d'autres pensent autrement.
Évidemment,
c’est très important de savoir de qui est
cette œuvre, qui a peint ce tableau.
C’est un maître hollandais du XVIIᵉ siècle
qui s’appelle Vermeer
et qui est très connu pour le traitement
qu’il fait de la lumière.
Ce tableau s’appelle
« La maîtresse et la servante ».
Mais si je vous l’avais dit avant, est-ce
que vous n’auriez pas regardé et dit :
« Ah oui, la maîtresse et la servante. »
Et vous seriez passé à autre chose.
Et le plaisir de découvrir
la relation entre ces deux femmes,
leur complicité,
de se demander ce que veut dire
cette main sur le menton,
d’essayer de savoir quelle histoire
le peintre a voulu raconter
et comment il l’a fait,
avec quelle composition,
avec quelle lumière, avec quelle couleur.
Le savoir est essentiel.
On a besoin de savoir
et d’avoir toutes ces informations.
Mais l’expérience qu’on en a
en regardant un tableau,
cette relation personnelle
qu’on a avec une œuvre,
laisse une empreinte beaucoup
plus profonde chez le spectateur,
car nous sortons d’un rôle passif,
celui de recevoir des informations,
et nous devenons acteur.
Aller dans un musée ou une galerie d’art
ne devrait pas être seulement l’occasion
d’enrichir nos connaissances
et d’apprendre plein de choses.
On devrait aussi pouvoir
y vivre l’expérience de l’art.
Qu’est-ce que c’est ?
C’est justement cette relation
qu’on crée avec une œuvre d’art.
C’est ce moment où on se laisse
emporter par une œuvre d’art
et qu’on ressent quelque chose,
qu’on est touché
par la beauté de ce qu’on voit.
Je vais vous raconter une expérience
que j’ai eue il y a plus de 20 ans.
Je suis allé voir l'exposition
de Kandinsky.
C’était à New York, au Guggenheim de Soho.
C’était l’exposition des aquarelles
de Kandinsky que je ne connaissais pas.
J’y vais avec une amie ;
nous rentrons dans la salle d’exposition,
une petite exposition.
Je commence à faire le tour
en regardant les tableaux.
Et là, au fur et à mesure que j’avançais,
j’ai senti une telle joie,
un tel bonheur, un tel plaisir,
d’être devant tant de beauté
que j’ai fait le tour
et j’ai refait le tour.
Puis je me suis arrêtée devant
un tableau qui m’avait
particulièrement plu.
Je me suis arrêtée,
j’ai regardé,
et là, j’ai senti cette émotion.
Cette émotion, cette joie, ce plaisir,
presque comme si j’étais en train
de partager quelque chose avec le peintre.
Une émotion très forte.
Je n'ai jamais oublié ce tableau.
Quand je suis sortie de cette exposition,
je n’avais qu’une seule envie :
voir plus d’art.
Car quand on fait l’expérience de l’art,
on veut en voir plus, on en veut encore.
Mais l’art de regarder ne s’applique pas
seulement à l’art,
ça s’applique aussi à notre vie
quotidienne, de tous les jours.
Quand nous allons à la boulangerie,
au supermarché,
quand nous allons travailler,
en général, nous ne regardons pas
autour de nous.
On pense à autre chose.
Alexandra Horowitz a écrit un livre
qui s’appelle « Le monde est magique »
où elle raconte l’expérience
qu’elle a faite avec onze personnes,
à qui elle demande de faire
le tour du pâté de maisons -
elle habite à New York -
et ensuite de lui raconter
ce qu’elles ont vu.
Elle dit la chose suivante :
« Lorsque on considère la rue
comme un être vivant,
on devient les investigateurs
de l’ordinaire.
Ce qui est familier devient inconnu
et ce qui est vieux devient nouveau. »
On s’émerveille.
C’est comme si on vivait dans un monde
d’un film en noir et blanc ou un peu flou.
Et lorsqu’on pose notre conscience
sur quelque chose,
cette chose devient colorée,
elle devient pleine de vie, nette.
En anglais,
s’émerveiller se dit « to wonder ».
J’aime beaucoup ce mot parce que,
au-delà de l’émerveillement,
il contient la curiosité, le doute,
et je trouve que ça ouvre
une autre porte à cet émerveillement.
Porter un regard holistique
en pleine conscience,
avec intention,
en étant ouvert à la découverte,
en étant sans a priori, sans juger.
apporte une nouvelle dimension
à notre vie.
Tout devient plus riche, plus complexe.
Aux États-Unis, les grandes facultés
de médecine aujourd’hui
enseignent le slow looking.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’ils pensent que
si les futurs médecins apprennent
à regarder de cette façon holistique,
bienveillante,
ils pourront voir leurs patients autrement
et ne pas les réduire
simplement à une maladie.
De même, dans notre vie
quotidienne de tous les jours,
lorsqu’on regarde un enfant
qui joue avec son père,
si on fait attention
à l’expression de l’enfant,
on pourra peut-être apprendre
beaucoup plus de choses
que si on faisait simplement attention
à ce qu’ils se disent ou ce qu’ils font.
Et dans votre vie, au bureau
ou même dans la rue, partout,
quand quelqu’un s’approche de vous
pour vous dire quelque chose,
si vous regardez,
si vous portez ce regard,
bienveillant, sans jugement,
mais vraiment présent,
c’est la même chose.
Peut-être que vous allez découvrir
beaucoup plus de choses
dans l’expression de la personne
et dans le langage du corps
de la personne.
Et pas seulement ça.
Si dans notre vie de tous les jours,
on s’arrêtait quelques secondes
pour regarder autour de soi,
en pleine conscience,
en prenant possession de l’espace,
à nouveau, sans a priori, sans jugement,
on arrive à diminuer le stress.
On sort du mode « Faire »
et on est dans le mode « Être ».
« Regarder s’apprend »,
disait Marguerite Duras.
En effet, regarder s’apprend.
Et ça se pratique
tous les jours au quotidien,
comme la méditation.
L’art de regarder,
qu’est-ce que c’est ?
Les mots-clés sont
« S’arrêter », « Prendre le temps ».
Dialoguer avec une œuvre, par exemple,
si on est dans un musée.
Dialoguer dans le sens où toute œuvre
a quelque chose à nous dire,
se laisser porter par ça.
Avoir une relation unique
avec ce qu’on voit.
C’est être présent dans le moment
et être en pleine conscience.
Ne pas avoir d’a priori
quand on regarde quelque chose.
Et je vous invite, lorsque vous irez
au musée la prochaine fois,
quand vous entrerez
dans une salle d’exposition,
ne commencez pas par lire tout
ce qu’il y a écrit, par vous informer.
D’abord faites le tour.
Regardez tous les tableaux de la salle.
Ensuite choisissez-en un.
Celui qui vous a le plus plu,
ou déplu, ou intrigué.
Arrêtez-vous devant cette œuvre
et regardez-la.
Regardez-la en voulant
communiquer avec elle,
en étant absolument présent et ouvert,
avec curiosité,
avec l’envie d’apprendre
quelque chose de cette œuvre.
Et ce soir, tout à l’heure,
quand vous quitterez cette salle,
si, sur le chemin de votre maison,
vous vous arrêtiez quelque part pour
regarder quelques secondes quelque chose,
avec cette intention,
avec cette curiosité,
avec cette conscience,
je pense que j’aurais
semé une petite graine.
Merci.